und jetzt schnell zu unserem reporter
paul ronzheimer in die hauptstadt nach
kiew dort
zugeschaltet paul sag uns einmal wie die
nacht war es gibt wohl immer mehr
hinweise dass es nicht läuft für die
russische armee kannst du das bestätigen
aus der hauptstadt
dhaka aus dem zentrum der hauptstadt in
kiew kann ich bestätigen das ist heute
nach im vergleichsweise wenig
explosionen wenig angriffe gegeben hat
zumindest was das zentrum angeht ist hat
kämpfe wie auch in den vergangenen tagen
in den außenbezirken gegeben aber auch
der große angriff der große
raketenangriff der große grad angriff
das was viele menschen ihr befürchtet
haben nachdem wir die schrecklichen
bilder aus haiti gesehen haben im osten
der stadt wo die gesamte stadt mit
ballistischen raketen system angegriffen
worden ist das hatte man für kiew
erwartet das ist in dieser nacht nicht
eingesteht das ist ein bisschen unklar
was genau passiert ist habe gestern
nacht mit vita liegt ist für den
bürgermeister darüber lange sprechen
können der gesagt hat unsere gegenwehr
ist viel stärker als bislang gedacht hat
ist gibt videos von russischen panzern
die von der ukrainischen armee zerstört
wurden komplett zerstört
angeblich soll über tausend russische
soldaten allein hier im umkreis
umgekommen seien getötet worden sein von
der ukraine stammen sind für uns nicht
nachprüfbar das den angaben des
ukrainischen militärs und der stadt
kehrt hier aber eins steht fest bei wenn
man sich anschauen wie die situation ist
und wie die situation eingeschätzt
worden war von analysten von den
menschen in russland auch teilweise und
ganz sicherlich auch ihr von
internationalen beobachtern dann steht
die ukrainische armee wesentlich besser
da als viele gedacht haben wie groß ist
die hoffnung in das treffen heute an
belarussische grenze
für dieses treffen da gibt es keine
hoffnung patricia da gab es die
vorbedingungen der russischen armee des
russischen staates wladimir putin der
immer wieder gesagt hat die ukraine die
existiert für ihn galt der ukraine das
existenzrecht abgesprochen er hat gesagt
dass die ukraine eine die
militarisierung akzeptieren müsse
akzeptieren müssen dass es niemals eine
nato mitgliedschaft geben wird und
akzeptieren müssen dass dort und du
kannst die beiden gebiete im osten
unabhängige volksrepublik würden das
alles ist für die ukraine niemals
umsetzbar das ist für diesen helden
präsident der er schon geworden ist wie
lenz geht nicht umsetzbar und es ist
auch nicht umsetzbar für die
internationale gemeinschaft wenn wir uns
anschauen dass ursula von der leyen die
eu kommissionspräsidenten in dieser
nacht mit selensky telefoniert hat am
abend und gesagt hat ihr gehört du uns
der europäischen union das ist ja
aussicht aus der wirren
logik von putin eine erneute provokation
weil das ist ja das was er immer
verhindert wollte auf keinen fall in der
eu auf keinen fall in die nato auf
keinen fall ein unabhängiger
demokratischer staat paul werden wir mit
dir sprechen sehen wir oben rechts noch
mal bilder von der grenze von der
ukraine nach polen also das sind
dramatische zahlen
500.000 menschen dort auf der flucht
innerhalb des landes oder eben vor allen
dingen raus aus der ukraine wie kannst
du im moment die moral der ukraine
einschätzen denn jetzt ist ja klar das
ist ja sozusagen alltag der krieg gehört
jetzt dazu das geht so schnell eben
nicht mehr weg das bleibt dauerhaft also
wie steht es um die moral der ukraine
auch wenn so viele das land verlassen
familien zerrissen sind
kein natürlich verlassen in so einer
situation hunderttausende menschen das
land natürlich wollen frauen und kinder
vor allem raus ältere menschen natürlich
will niemand
aber gleichzeitig dieser tempel
widerstand der hier auch in kiew
organisiert worden ist das ist schon
etwas was viele auch diesem land nicht
zugetraut haben und ganz sicher wladimir
putin nicht zugetraut hat dem müssen
offenbar seine berater gesagt haben
greift die drei vier tage an dann werden
die stunde die waffen niederlegen und
das auch in ihr fall so damit hat er
nicht gerechnet und wenn man sich hier
umschaut in der stadt und mit den
menschen spricht was natürlich schwierig
ist aufgrund der ausgangssperre die
allerdings heute vormittag wieder
aufgehoben werden soll da wird man sehen
wie das leben in der stadt möglich ist
denn du musst wissen das ganze ist die
ausgeschaltet 636 stunden niemand mehr
auch nicht auf der straße komplettes
verbot dafür bis eben auf diese zivile
verteidigung allerdings das wirklich
gefährliche das wirklich noch
dramatischere steht dieser stadt bevor
denn der angriff da bin ich ganz sicher
der noch massivere angriff russlands
gekommen und damit gehen viele
beobachter auch davon aus dass
vielleicht diese friedensgespräche volg
laden wir ziehen einfach dafür genutzt
werden um hier militär taktisch und
strategisch einfach die truppen zu legen
die stets aktuell um die versorgung der
hauptstadt kiew also gibt's da engpässe
hat man da was zu essen was zu trinken
wie kommt der nachschub nicht hat
noch gibt es möglichkeiten in die stadt
zu kommen das ist ganz wichtig vitali
klitschko hat das gestern ein bild
klargestellt es gab eine meldung und
nach angeblich hier komplett
eingekesselt sei die nachrichtenagentur
pti für den bürgermeister so verstanden
haben klitschko sagte zu mir nein die
stadt ist nicht komplett eingekesselt es
gibt weiterhin wege in die stadt das
heißt auch die versorgung funktioniert
noch aber der bürgermeister redet nicht
um den heißen brei herum bist bist du
das natürlich die versorgungslage
schwierig bis dramatisch ist das
natürlich auch die
nahrungssituation schwieriger wird weil
es nicht mehr einfach ist hier material
rein zu bekommen das ist der völlig
blass und möglicherweise ist das eben
auch eine strategie von wladimir putin
dass er weiter versucht die stadt
einzusetzen dass es ihm irgendwann
gelingen sollte und dass er dann die
säge dicht macht das nichts mehr hier zu
uns kommt dass man nahrungsmittel nicht
mehr in die stadt lassen könnte dass man
medikamente nicht mehr in die stadt
kommen könnten das wäre dann das
druckmittel dass putin eventuell braucht
um hier die lenski in eine richtung zu
bewegen aber noch ist davon nichts zu
spüren noch ist ein präsident zu sehen
ein ukrainischer präsident der wie ich
gerade schon gesagt hat nicht nur die in
der ukraine langsam zum helden wird
sondern auch international genauso wie
die gebrüder weiter seite an seite jede
nach jeden tag hier in der stadt in der
verteidigung ihrer stadt wir schaffen es
bislang vor allem die moral hochgehalten
und das kann patrick der ist etwas was
völlig anders ist als 2014 als ich auch
hier war in der ukraine hat die
russischen truppen auf der krim 1 4 da
stand ich vor einer ukrainischen kaserne
und die soll da die sind einfach raus
gelaufen haben ihre waffen abgelegt und
sind entweder in die ukraine gefahren
oder sind zu russland übergelaufen er
ist nicht mal ein schuss gefallen das
ist heute komplett anders paul
ronzheimer uns zugeschaltet aus kiew
vielen herzlichen dank der